This video is brought to you by keeps.
What's up guys, Greg Michael,
here time-traveling movies has a weird history to say the least,
whether it's a DeLorean juiced up to 1.2, one gigawatts,
a germ filled hot tub or Keanu Reeves.
It's basically always a certifiable mind trip.
And yet we keep returning to these stories because they tickle our brains with
one very compelling question.
Do we have any free will to change the future or are the awful things that
happened to us? Inevitable.
Enter dark this German Netflix series centers around a small forest town whose
residence time traveled across centuries,
trying to change a tragic chain of events,
their ultimate goal avoid an off disgust.
Phillips. [inaudible].
The question of whether or not they can do anything about their impending doom
is the core of the show's mystery and make no mistake.
This show we'll have you up at 3:00 AM,
a hundred comments deep on a Reddit thread about dark's incestuous family tree.
But more on that later, they're really important question to pose is, is this,
do we have the power to prevent our own suffering?
And is it even worth trying to let's find out in this wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of dark and as always spoilers ahead. But before we continue,
I want to give a shout out to this week. Sponsor keeps I love wearing hats.
They're pretty much part of my identity.
You probably feel the same way about your hair. It's something people recognize,
and it's probably one way you express yourself.
If you've ever been scared of losing anything, keeps can put your mind at ease,
keeps us in affordable hair loss treatment program that provides FDA approved
prescription and over-the-counter medication with keeps.
There's no trip to the doctor or awkward pharmacy pickup involved.
You can do everything right from the comfort of your own home.
You meet with a doctor virtually and can get the medication delivered right to
your door. Keeping your hair is all about prevention.
So the sooner you take action,
the more hair you can save with keeps some men even report hair regrowth,
find out why it keeps has more five-star reviews than any of its competitors.
And why nearly 100,000 men trust keeps for their hair loss prevention
medication. By clicking the link in the description,
or by going to keeps.com/wisecrack. If you use our link,
you can get 50% off your first three months, stop stressing and keep your hair.
Now back to the show. And now a quick recap, dark tells the story of winded,
rural town face in a series of tragic, but seemingly normal events.
This all quickly spirals into time, travel,
accidental incest and interdimensional disaster. So first a guy kills himself.
Then a boy goes missing. And then the son of the guy who killed himself,
Jonas starts looking for the missing boy via a literal wormhole to the past.
There,
he learns that the missing boy has been living in 1986 and will grow up to
become his dad. Oh, and meanwhile,
a whole lot of other folks are also secretly messing with time travel to
eventually the people have wind in from as far back as 1888 to as far forward as
2053, discover that they are trapped in a perpetual unchangeable time loop.
That always ends in a horrible apocalypse. Oh yeah.
And finds out that his crushed Martha is in fact his aunt. Yikes.
So let's take this one season at a time.
All our characters are using time-travel to try to fix or change the future,
but do they even have that power or are they cursed to stay trapped in this
rainy,
suburban hell of a time loop midway through the season Jonas and the people of
wind and discover the wormhole beneath her town and attempt to correct or change
the central event.
The young boys disappearance at first Jonas thinks he has free will and that his
choices will determine his fate and the fate of the missing boy.
But a mysterious stranger tells him that taking the boy back to 2019 would
result in the end of Jonas's own existence because this kid is his father and
needs to grow up in the past in order to, you know,
father Jonas examples like this are numerous and the results are always the
same. Every time someone tries to change the past,
they're actually just doing something that by necessity has already happened.
And as the characters attempts to change the past are continuously forwarded.
They slowly realized that they don't have free will rather they seem to be
trapped in an endless cycle. That's outside their control.
We can understand this endless cycle with a little help from Arthur
Schopenhauer, who side note was a horrible hand. According to Schopenhauer,
the world is driven by an animating force called will.
This will rather than our own individual choices.
What drives our actions will compels us to eat, breathe, sleep, and importantly,
to try to avoid suffering. It's like will be underpaid bus driver.
And we're all passengers stuck in the back of the bus,
unable to get off and dark characters like Jonas struggled to accept this
reality as they continue to believe that they are in fact,
the driver of their own bus, able to change history with their own will.
In fact,
one character's determination to change the future makes him behave so radically
that he gets put in a mental institution in the past. It can be harder,
even impossible to accept that we don't really have control over anything we do
after all we experienced life as a series of actions and the consequences of
those actions.
So even as teen Jonas realizes that all of his choices have been predetermined.
The mysterious stranger who is actually adult Jonas from the future,
keeps trying to change the fabric of reality by destroying the wind and
wormhole.
Wait, wait, I'm gonna get after this, it's been
candies. [inaudible]
[inaudible], [inaudible].
Only problem. Even this event has already happened.
And we learned that adult Jonas's attempt to close the worm hole is what
actually creates it in the first place.
Because your stoner friends from college ganja, Greg was right.
Time is an illusion.
The characters keep messing up their lives because they can't accept that time
is not a one-way street of sequential events.
Rather the things they do in the present can actually affect the past.
They like we experienced time as linear and tend to assume that's the
reality. In fact time, according to dark and also, you know,
Einstein is happening all at once everywhere. And every time of course,
people of dark might've realized their faith sooner.
If they could have read the first season's opening quote by Einstein himself,
the distinction between the past present and future is only a stubbornly
persistent illusion by season two,
our characters start to learn that not only are they unable to change the past,
but they are also completely unable to stop trying to why you guessed it.
The force of will. And in this case, the will to stop their own suffering.
Everyone in wind, in his dealing with emotional wounds,
Jonas can't get over his father's suicide. His mother feels rejected by the men.
She loves various people are hurt by their spouses, infidelities,
and many people die tragically, one character,
Claudia experiments with time travel,
hoping to save her daughter who gets cancer in the future,
as well as her father who was murdered in the past and Jonas far in the future
tries to save Martha,
his aunt slash lover and everyone else he loves from the end of the world is
constantly trying to stop bad things from happening without succeeding sounds
awful. That's because it is in fact,
the very will that makes us take action to avoid suffering.
Simultaneously drives us to further suffering. According to Schopenhauer,
the world of daily life actually just is suffering and trying to prevent that
suffering just makes us more miserable. Like we said,
not a fun hang by this point,
the people of wind and may have realized that they're not in control of
anything, but they're also not sure who is that's.
When the show suggests that there might be some kind of higher being pulling all
the strings.
It introduces add a godlike dude in a church like room who seems very bossy.
So is Adam God, hell no.
He's just an older and uglier version of Jonas in a literalization of
Schopenhauer. His philosophy,
young Jonas's innocent desire to save his town from suffering,
leads him to grow into Adam,
an ugly thing responsible for much of his town's suffering.
We see this again at the climax of season two,
as both young Jonas and adult Jonas are trying to stop the death of Martha Young
Jonas. Then she dies during the apocalypse,
but adult Jonas knows she dies by gunshot in a sick irony.
Adult Jonas forces her into a bunker with the very gun that all Jonah's
AKA Adam will one day use to murder. Martha is your brain, okay?
Right now mine's not. But anyway, Jonas's desire to save.
Martha ends up being the very thing that sets all the pieces in place to get her
killed. By his own hand,
the creators of dark seemed to agree about the inevitability of certain human
behaviors. According to the show's writer, Jontay freeze.
It always comes down to some kind of programming they had before them that you
can not choose because you can not let go of this stuff that happened before
you,
your past is always pushing you into the direction you're going while at the
same time, the future is pulling you,
but there's still one more season of the show.
Is there any hope for our time traveling incest babies?
There is if they can learn to like your laconic teenage brother,
just give less of it. We'll let the show explain season three,
roots it's conflict and the tension between two mirror worlds,
one light and one dark, which are both fighting for control of time travel.
Naturally. Everyone believes that they on the good side,
even as they do very bad things like repeatedly killed their own family members.
So have grown-up Jonas, AKA Adam is the mastermind of one mirror world.
What's going down on the other side. They're in the parallel mirror world.
We have Martha now called Eve when mirror Martha kidnaps Jonas.
At the end of season two,
we crossover into this mirror timeline where things are sort of different,
but mostly the same. These mirror worlds in the war between Adam and Eve,
AKA old,
Jonas and old Martha might make us wonder who's on the right side of this FDF
history. If there's new free will and no architect of fate,
is there even such a thing as good and evil,
not according to your favorite party, ruiner Schopenhauer. If the world is,
will, it's an endless striving with no end in sight,
devoid of knowledge and law entirely free.
And self-determining within Schopenhauer is vision.
There is no God to be comprehended.
The world is inherently meaningless and therefore beyond any descriptions of
good and evil.
So neither Adam Nora Eve is right or wrong as if to literalize this point,
Jonas and Martha's interdimensional baby.
A human trilogy of antichrist seems to be,
single-handedly trapping everyone in this hellish timescale and the ultimate
interdimensional custody battle. They fight over how to deal with their demon.
Baby. Martha has a maternal desire to keep him alive and Jonas wants him dead.
Hoping it will put an end to this ugly time, moral of the story,
maybe having a baby with your aunt from another dimension, isn't the best idea.
And in case you thought we were stretching with all the Schopenhauer stuff.
Season three opens with this quote by the German Lord himself,
man can do what he wills, but he cannot will what he wills.
And the show reaffirms this view by revealing a few remaining secrets about the
town's closed time loop. The apocalypse is unavoidable.
Jonas dad can't be saved no matter what. Oh,
and also a number of people end up being their own parent and or grandparent,
which would lead to the world's weirdest 23 and me results ever. And again,
everything is inevitable and infinitely repeating.
So upon realizing all of this, what can Jonas and Martha do well,
they can commit a weird type of metaphysical suicide by preventing the event
which created each of their timelines in the first place,
by denying their desire to fix their suffering. They might be able to find,
we move past it in a way this is an extreme,
the self-denial that Schopenhauer describes as one cure for human suffering.
According to Schopenhauer,
this type of self sacrifice helps us give up the desire to find meaning and
purpose in our suffering.
It's sort of his cranky German version of the moral wisdom that Buddhist monks
have practice long before Netflix was a thing Jonas attempts to remedy his
suffering by ending his own life and those of everyone around him,
but this doesn't work. Instead,
the creators of dark robbed me of another peaceful slumber by creating a third
dimension, which proceeds the timelines of both Adam and Eve, the origin world.
And it turns out our mural worlds only exist in the first place because of
distraught scientist and clockmaker and the origin world tried to build a time
machine that accidentally reality into those two timelines.
And it's only by stopping the painful event that motivated this mishap,
that Jonas and Martha can destroy their own worlds completely and stop the
endless cycle of suffering. Unfortunately,
doing so will turn them everyone they know,
and all those incest babies into sparkly dust.
It's the senior to you.
But wait, what about the will to live according to Schopenhauer,
if you were to truly realize how hopelessly immoral human nature is,
you'd be so disgusted by the pointless driving of will.
That you'd simply deny it. Like you give up the will to live, resign yourself,
to what it is,
and actually find some tranquility in doing so basically once you realize how
cruelly everything is,
you're able to stop giving and this worry about your suffering a lot less and
Jonas and Martha having fully realized all of this peacefully make the choice to
correct the origin world by saving the clockmakers family in the origin world,
thereby erasing the tragedy that brought themselves into existence.
But isn't this sad,
not really an accepting their role in the perpetuation of suffering across the
multiple generations and timelines.
They're able to do something both moral and selfless, which is to simply let go.
And the show's final scene at a dinner party with the only characters whose
existence hasn't been raised. One character, Hannah describes a dream.
[Inaudible] not take us
to satisfy bias.
So it sounds a lot like Schopenhauer is tranquility in self denial.
This sentiment that the world is better off without Windon has been previously
expressed.
Innovate.
The repetition of this idea drives home the theme of the show and wind and to
erase the world is to erase the tragedy and suffering of existence,
which seems like a total bummer from one perspective.
But the show makes a final choice that actually veers away from Schopenhauer a
bit. Hahna says, she's thinking of naming her new baby Jonas,
and you can make a VAT, vaguely hopeful note, what you will,
maybe it means that there's a future somewhere for Jonas and Martha to be
together after all, or maybe everything is forever.
And your dad is your crushes little brother and your crushes, your aunt,
and by some weird logic, your mother is also your great, great, great,
great grandmother. And why can't Germans just make a happy show.
But what do you think is dark the ultimate exploration of a totally
deterministic universe? Or is there another way to read the ending?
Let us know in the comments big, thanks to our patrons for all your support,
destroy that subscribe button. Like it is the fabric of space and time.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Later.
Is there someone there? Is this the thing? Did I do the thing, right?
Do you guys have any snacks.